[Music]
welcome back again to the what podcast
which bands this year that matter
there's lord taco back at it nice see
you buddy
we're all rinsed out all dried up we'll
see can't wait to hear how that week
went are we i don't know i don't know if
i believe there's barry corder barry
corder looking like you uh just got a
fresh cut did barry quarters get a fresh
cut i've got this
boris what's his name the the english
yeltsin no what's the the ink johnson i
don't know what's johnson yes
i gotta say if you're making a boris
yeltsin reference we have gotten way way
way too old that's how old i am yeah you
remember the czar
um how's everybody doing
good first time the whole team's been
together in a while
yeah i really didn't want to hear about
taco's trip
oh yeah taco came to new orleans and i
um i my job was to take him to every
dive bar in the city
and i think we did it
uh i think we missed a few so i'll have
to come back for another round i love
these spears
i love the spirit yeah
the guy's got a never-ending attitude he
never wants to stop and that's what's
going to make him successful
what are these days i'm going to make it
yeah i i did hear you uh you you you
broke out a little bit you you had not
only uh your regular 12 ounce but a
couple of 16 ounces and some draft
that's right i tried all the flavors it
was crazy you went crazy down there i
heard draft cans bottles 12 16 he tried
uh so many different variations of pbr
that um you know
it must at this point it better be russ
blue ribbon they just should change the
name to russ blue river you know if
you're if you're going to go to new
orleans you might as well go all out so
i respect you
he went all out he showed boobs it was
nuts
it was nuts
slept on the floor too like a real new
orleanian he uh yes it screw it this
looks good to me
we were worried about you on monday
because we couldn't find you couldn't
find it yeah i overslept monday sorry
about that yeah you were afraid you were
like you know on the side of a road or a
ditch or so if you don't know lord taco
being in uh north georgia bury quarters
in chattanooga i'm in new orleans and
and for the first time uh one of my
podcast pals came and visited me now uh
i knew it'd never be
barry quarter because barry has not left
the state since the 80s
so
luckily and luckily i got rust to come
down and it was your first time since
when you hadn't been here in a while
first time i went to new orleans was
2013 and we just did all the typical
bourbon street
hurricanes all the tourist stuff we
never really ventured far out of that so
this time actually got to go into the
all the side neighborhoods and all the
where the locals go and what taco said
that i loved so much when he got here
he's like every neighborhood it's just
like house house house bar house house
house bar house house house bar and
that's really the wa the way i love uh
the thing i love the most about it is
all the great spots are just in between
a couple of houses
whereas here it's house house house
church house house house church
what's the difference
well
the uh the trip was actually a lot of
fun you know
russ is one of these guys that you know
you you
he can fit into any shape you pour him
into right so it doesn't matter
what you decide to do he's always game
for it and it's very flexible yeah so
when i say so should we go to this bar
his answer is yeah yeah we should do
that yeah
yeah it was a very last-minute decision
because uh kelsey was the one who
decided to go and she was like hey i'm
got some days off i'm going to go you
want to go i'm like
can't say can't say why not so and i
need someone in the car with her and
yeah well i ended up driving her but
either way uh but yeah she was like oh i
want to go to this store and this
restaurant and this fancy place and this
and i'm a shopping trip for her and so
what did were me and you were going to
do
exactly so i was just like yeah whatever
let's go let's go to a bar let's go
let's go start drinking
drinking
we only we did the quarter we did a day
in the quarter and we bounced around and
i think that uh taco's favorite place is
a place called the golden lantern he was
a big fan of the golden lantern
it was it was nice it was yeah
and then it was cheerful and then i took
him
barry
to the white whale
the grand puba the greatest of the great
the greatest bar
in the world
i will put everything that i have on it
the greatest place
on the planet and that's
what taco
pals
the pals lounge yes is that the one
right near you yes it's near me and it's
gotten to the point where um when you
know we go to move and buy a house it
will be within 500 yards draw a circle
around pals because i cannot leave
my favorite spot in the world
is that where you did the challenge
no that was at snake and jake's yeah so
then so then the next night we go we do
the palace thing and pals is you know to
me just the best bar on the planet and
then
go back let's go back why sure why okay
yeah well taco you start because i blow
v8 a lot and i don't want to like
oversell it so let's see what taco has
about
yeah
they've got a great jukebox they have
one of the best dive bar bathrooms that
i've seen yeah um they've got great art
on the wall i'm gonna need more detail
what's on the jukebox that makes it
special and what's special about this
bathroom yeah so first off a couple
things i am uh doing a uh i think i'm
gonna start do when i can start i've
already started but i'm gonna make a
dive bar bathroom field guide of new
orleans that is just pictures of
great dive bar bathrooms in the city and
um i wanted to basically be a guide to
you know
the the crown jewels and to me the great
dive bar bathrooms the great dive bars
in this world have great bathrooms and
they can't be clean they can't be you
know pristine and you know filled with
beautiful tile and stainless steel no
they they got to have character they've
got to have they don't have they don't
have the glass bowl sink no they don't
want a glass the waterfalls yeah i don't
want that
i want okay that's not it no i want
character i want it to i want it to be
its own entity right and i want it to be
the thing that like you know just by
looking at it
that's
that place right and so i've gone around
the city and i've taken some of like 150
photos of dive bar bathrooms and i want
to do a picture field guide of the great
dive bar bathrooms in the in new orleans
because there's so many so
when i walked into the pals bathroom
it's
the crown jewel it's the greatest angel
started singing and all that
i mean
it's close i don't want to give it away
i don't want to tell you what's what's
adorning the walls i don't want to tell
you how you walk into the bathroom
because it's just such a glorious
space um so then that in itself is is
such a great part of it the jukebox
berry oh my god um you know you go from
dolly parton to prince
and it's so hand curated by the people
that work there and that's the other
thing that's important to me about a
great dive bar it's got to have a great
jukebox and it cannot be it cannot be
touch tunes
you cannot give me a spotify playlist
it's got to be hand curated by the
people that work there okay and taco was
there on a very special day because i
had gotten to the jukebox and i always
have like a pretty good idea of what my
set's going to be right and uh so i get
to the jukebox and i notice
they've added the very first ever b52 cd
oh i was so excited it was a new
addition when you get a new edition of
the jukebox in 2022 it's like it's
christmas morning and so i'm so excited
i've got a new song i'm going to add to
the playlist it's the first song in that
first album i love that song so much so
that i put it on track one
hit play
and the damn thing just starts skipping
oh no i mean we missed it it's a cd yeah
song and so the next day me and taco go
to record stores and try and find the
b-52 cd so that we can replace it
into the into the jukebox and so uh i
talked to the girl who runs the place
and i said so i i went to find a new cd
for the jukebox and she said no no no no
no no no we
we
will curate the jukebox like no i don't
want to give you a new cd i want to
replace the cd that you already have and
she's like oh okay i can die i just love
the like the care that they're willing
to put into this jukebox that no no
you're not you're not putting something
in that we don't approve i love that
okay also
go ahead they also followed me on
instagram that's the only bar that we
went to that followed me on instagram
nice it's a big deal so uh real quick my
nephew
opened a bar here in chattanooga called
lo main it's on main street
and
he has a really good graham has an
unbelievable
taste so he's curated
their soundtrack but we had a board
meeting for a group that i'm on and
it was a four o'clock meeting and on the
tv well on the jukebox they were playing
slade which was pretty cool to begin
with but on the tv they were playing uh
a clockwork orange
the unedited version so you can imagine
that's another good that's a good pull
because in impals all they do is show
like really old campy horror movies well
star trek was on the one other time we
were there early star trek but but you
can imagine a board meeting
with you had half the table with their
backs to the tv and the other half
facing it so i was watching
with their back because you can see the
faces
if you don't if you've never seen the
movie it's pretty graphic
the rape scenes and the brut
there's a really good uh here this
this is a mark of a really great bar
right i don't like tvs and bars because
it's distracting and the whole point of
being there is to have a conversation
chit chat whatever but if you're gonna
have tvs in there
there could be major sporting events
happening in this city there could be
saints games happening and
they've still got you know goofy horror
movies the kitschy horror movies from
the 80s
[Laughter]
so so anyway so we do that one day then
the next night we decide to take taco to
the legendary snake and jakes where
if you're a new bonnaroovian you don't
know this but for years and years and
years because of the the roots of
bonnaroo being in new orleans and half
of the the organization being from new
orleans superfly
they brought some of the new orleans
flair to
the uh the festival the first few years
there was a second line that always
happened on thursday you know they
there's always sort of a parade that
happened and then there was the snake
and jake's christmas barn inside cenaru
well that is from an actual place here
in new orleans and you know if you
didn't
if you didn't already know that there's
no possible way that you would know it
because when you walk up to snake and
jakes it is the tiniest bar you've ever
seen in your life so if you didn't know
that snake and jakes was already a
pre-existing space in this world walking
up to it in bonnaroo it's like oh this
is this weird place called snaken jigs
so
taco tell barry your experience with the
actual snake and jigs
uh it was good uh the lighting was good
the bathroom's good uh the lighting by
the way it's pitch black with nothing
but red lights everywhere oh i look
great
so your first your first night at snake
and jake's you did what
we did the pbr challenge pbr challenge
the bartender was so excited about this
we put three beers up against each other
one was a high life one was a pbr and
then one was a
um schlitz schlitz that's right we tried
to get hams we actually tried to get
hams for the kids the ham's kids but
no can do so we get the slits um we get
the high life and taco is ready to go i
mean he's never been more confident in
anything in his life and then what
happened
i picked high life
happy had to go through twice i listened
yeah i mean i went back and forth
i'm proud of you for for not only you
know telling this story but coming on
this show and telling this story because
you must be ashamed it's the walk of
shame this is the walk of shame for time
i'm not ashamed i got three free beers
wait a second the schlitz you gave to me
because you hated it so much no i drank
the schlitz i thought you gave me the
slits oh i had a lot of [ __ ]
switch also brewed by paps by the way
really i didn't know that oh there we go
hey we have guests okay we got some
guests uh hi guys how are you
good how are you guys i'm doing super
we're doing good
we're we're talking dive bars yeah we
kind of got
sidetracked in a dive bar we haven't
talked festivals at all yeah we're
dogging dive bars so what is your how do
you guys define a dive bar what's your
favorite
uh dark dank
out of the way
hole in the wall
yeah not a lot of selection
yeah and it's got to be cheap yeah very
cheap yeah that's rule number one yeah
you nailed it and and to me you're not
gonna be a real dive bar unless you have
the appropriate bathroom and if your
bathroom is not divy and gross and a
little bit seedy and you know
got critters running around in the
corners i just don't i don't buy it i
think that you're i think you're
parading around and trying to say that
you're a diver there's a dive bar here
in town um that
we affectionately say it's gotten
huzzied up
so they put a new coat of paint on the
outside and they painted the inside now
the drinks are still cheap they're still
strong and it's still open 24 hours but
you walk into the bathroom and they've
painted the damn thing purple and put
prince pictures all over the place
nice you're not a dive bar anymore no
you're not just we decided uh that the
glass bowl sinks and uh water fountain
or waterfall uh you know faucets
the olive garden is a bigger dive bar
than you are at this point yeah um
so
the reason why we had by the way
introduce our guest there barry and then
we'll get the show actually going you
guys spent plenty of time actually let
taco taco has met these folks so
i did yeah um
good to see you again yeah we ran into
each other or you know at the uh mark
rubelli show
loop daddy in chattanooga
the third pronunciation that i've
heard i don't think i've gotten it right
anytime i don't know what it is
uh it's pronounced i'm telling it's
pronounced merc
okay yeah okay you're right yeah
good but um
yeah uh bonnaroo got cancelled and you
know we went to the uh mini roo up in
winchester and
me and um
david bruce uh i'm bonner we decided to
take a trip to chattanooga and see that
loop daddy show and
ran into these guys and then met up
afterwards and went to a bar and just
had a good night
and y'all are from knoxville is that
correct
yes yeah yeah
yeah we were just looking for something
to do after bonnaroo got cancelled so
that's how we ended up course yeah and
uh yeah what made you pick chattanooga
just
something to do or
yeah well mark was actually the the
first of the artists uh after everything
got cancelled that had the complete show
lineup ready to go and we're like well
you know we really wanted to see him at
bonnaroo so
that's true they really they really
pulled that show out quick
yeah yeah
it was within minutes
the reason why we wanted to have you
guys on and uh forgive us for doing a
little background here real quick is
because uh we wanted to spend this
episode talking not about dive bars but
about boston calling right last week we
were going through festival lineup after
festival lineup and then we you know it
struck me
every single year boston calling just
it feels like they just hit home run
after home run and you know you do a
little bit of digging and you start
realizing that this this festival is is
quite well done and the thing that i
didn't know barry boston calling
completely independent operation
in 2013 they started and i didn't know
this either they started as a fall
spring festival so they did two of them
and
it all began because aaron desner from
the national
said
i don't know let's let's do it let's do
a thing now i don't know how a
cincinnati kid
uh and part-time cincinnati part-time
new york then finds himself in boston
curating a music festival lineup but go
to 2013 go to 2014 go to the fall of
2014. there is not a lineup
that they have curated that is not
incredible absolutely incredible now the
thing that i don't know anything about
is uh the grounds i know they changed uh
facilities somewhere in in the you know
2014 or i don't know they changed at
some point and went to a new place i
don't know anything about the grounds i
have only been to boston once so we
wanted to sort of you know
fill in the blanks of what boston
calling is um because i tell you
you know it got my attention last year i
got my attention the year before got my
attention before that but it must be a
southern thing that because we have
shaky knees and we have bonnaroo these
these sort of northeastern festivals
just go right by us barry and we don't
pay any attention to them yeah but you
and i talked about it a little bit on
the show um
and then uh jessica
sent us an email and uh basically said
you should check it out so
you know being clever like i am i said
come on the show and tell us about it so
that's why you're here
clever is saying can someone else do the
work for me i i that's the cleverness
yes
that's how i live my life too
yeah let somebody else do the heavy
lifting that's sure well let's go ahead
yeah so let's start yeah and go and uh
talk to you in 45 minutes
so
so
tell me
so you guys have been
yes yes all right so so why did you
choose this festival what year did you
go and what was the reason for it
well it's kind of twofold i have family
up there so it's easy for me to go visit
but i really wanted to go we went in
2018.
um and the reason i like them is because
you can get uh different regional acts
you don't see here um in the southeast
they were actually um belly was part of
the lineup that year
you know the alt rock band belly with
tonya donnelly from the throwing uses
she was one of my favorites and um
that's why i wanted to go see the band
to begin with but then i
talked to my cousins and we just all
decided to go
um
and you know boston's a fun place to
visit
yeah it was just really one of those uh
it kind of met the moment
at that time and it was like well you
know we have a big gap in between them
because i've only been going to
festivals for
well
three or four years now officially since
a lot of things have been canceled but
uh
yeah it just
it felt right and then especially for
last year when everything was supposed
to happen again we had signed up to
to go to the 2021 and then you know that
got pushed out so okay well let's let's
start with just basic setup um
where is the festival held and how far
outside of the city center is it um
well it's moved like you said it used to
be downtown but they moved it out to the
harvard athletic fields so it's it's
right
um to the west of boston you know over
near cambridge and als it's in alston um
it's just south of cambridge but it's
totally accessible it's on their subway
system the tea
um you could easily get to the festival
from anywhere else and i think that's um
one of the draws because you can it's
you know in a city that's pretty
accessible for other
areas so so close enough to be
considered a city fest huh oh yeah for
sure okay yeah all right i would call it
like a suburb almost of boston
i think you said in your email it's very
walkable yeah you just you hit it but
also the the trains the t gets you there
it's pretty easy so
i mean how how close are you able to
stay you know hotel wise and all that
see that's different for us because the
way you have family right yeah we stayed
with family and then just took the train
into town so it was a lot easier but i'd
say it's pretty accessible i mean
because of the subway system obviously
you could stay in cambridge or
somerville or
um anywhere along the subway line and
it'd be a pretty easy um ride and then
walk to the festival when are they when
are they wanting you out
when is the uh sort of like shutdown
time uh
it does end at about 11. yeah like most
cities normal city festival gotcha all
right so when you walk in uh what is the
setup like uh and and could you compare
it to any other festival that is the
same sort of size it actually reminds me
a lot of shaky knees in that like all of
the the way the acts are set up and the
stages are set up it's very back to back
to back so you go from one show to the
next show to the next show like there is
no really down time and how many stages
are there three four i think there's
four this year for sure yeah okay yeah
plus they have the uh the athletic
complex that they'll do comedy shows or
you know in the hockey arena so it's
it's air-conditioned people like to go
in it's nice so kind of like the old
comedy tents that they had up on a room
well wait a second is the weather bad in
march
is it way to say it's not in march it's
memorial day weekend okay but is it is
it hot in boston and memorial day it
depends
really okay we've been when it's been
warm but then it also can be cold and
rainy you know it's the northeast yeah
interesting and you
just to give people an idea you've been
to bonner how many times have you been
to bonnaroo um i've been six times and
reggie's been
twice officially three or four times
unofficially
what is that
or you didn't get in or what no there's
this thing called coven yes right
oh i got your carpet
you're not telling your boss you win is
it your first day uh
[Laughter]
i got you um what other festivals have
you been to are you shaking these i
assume yeah shaky knees lollapalooza
um we've been overseas to mad cool and
rock worked her
no kidding you did man cool huh oh yeah
why in the world did you choose that
bill
i agree
whatever he
said
the lineup that year uh in 2018 was the
same year that we went to uh to boston
it was really set up
so well it was a slam dunk of a lineup
who was on it what was what was the draw
let's see so we had depeche mode uh
queens of the stone age nine inch nails
uh
alice in chains yeah but this is this is
this is in madrid so
i have to say
how in the hell you guys getting all
this time off
well it's what we use for our vacations
yeah it's just our yearly vacation so
it's kind of blocked out the time of
like don't expect us to be here for
about a week do you guys do you guys set
out to do like an international festival
or did this one just just make too much
sense and work out perfectly it made a
lot of sense because also at the time uh
we had a friend that lived in belgium
and so
it ended up that we were going to just
go straight to madrid and then it's like
well you know we how often are we going
to do this so then we bounce to
barcelona
belgium
turkey eventually happened during that
trip so yeah barry if you're not if you
don't know these are foreign countries
[Laughter]
so i can't get there from here you're
not going to be able to drive no
no i'm not going barry historically
doesn't leave the state of tennessee
can i see him can i see him from my
basement
that was so you guys would be you're
you're the perfect person to ask um
can you compare them how do you how do
they compare
and i mean not necessarily rate though
if you can rate them that would be okay
but
it's the comparison i'm more interested
in
it is a lot more efficient
i guess it's the best way to say it
which means
uh
both of them actually rockworker and mad
cool
they're the the ones overseas yeah the
ones overseas for boss and calling um
i would rank it about at the same level
as shaky knees just as far as um
the ease of being able to get to it but
you know it's a normal city festival in
that way but it's kind of in the heart
of the city
so you know hang on a second you said
you said the i've always had this
feeling that there is there's a massive
difference between an international
festival and an american festival what
do you mean by more efficient
i i would say it's because they've been
around for so long um they just know you
know
they know what works yeah so for
comparison this is something we only saw
overseas it was crazy they actually had
people walking around with backpacks
these large um backpacks full of beer
and they would come around and they
could fill your cup while you're waiting
in the crowd so you didn't have to leave
that's what taco does that's tough yeah
[Laughter]
so
okay so
so
beer efficiency what else what else is
is efficient about it that you like uh
do you feel like the setup is better yes
the stages were set up where there
wasn't a lot of sound bleed i think
there was one issue that
uh one of the bands that was supposed to
be at mad cool didn't actually play
because
sound bleed from where they were but
that had to do with the tent issue of
just where it was located um
but other than that it was
they also had a craft um a craft beer
and cocktail area it rockworked
uh that it was closed off so they
actually gave you
glass
yeah they gave you glassware to actually
use but you could only use it in that
area brad that sounds like the uh
bourbon tint in louisville when yeah and
you embarrassed me in front of uh ashley
capps i did not embarrass you front of
ashley capps i said something true and
you agreed and but you yeah yeah and
then and then we hugged
we all hugged it was funny well i was
going to say we we hugged brittany
howard but um but what hang on a second
when you said that when he said that the
uh the the are the grounds bigger or do
they take up more space is that because
the sound bleed is is better there
because they just take they have a lot
more accessible areas
what is it about the international
festival mad cool especially that
doesn't have you know the the sound
issues
um i think it's the way they set up the
stages because they're kind of
perpendicular and um it's the direction
uh that the sound is going and the way
that they they move the bands in and out
it's always facing a different way but
you don't have to walk very far we
literally were watching depeche mode on
one stage
turned you know turned around and nine
inch nails was starting we didn't we
barely didn't have to move at all
our moon river festival is like that and
i was just thinking uh we have a band
here in town called glass hammer which
is an internationally
known prague rock band
and they did a european uh festival
three years ago i guess
and i was stunned to hear them tell me
that basically it's a city-run festival
they literally fence off the entire city
and it shuts down for that weekend
and once you buy your ticket you're in
it it's you're in that little small town
that's not what you're talking about
right it's it's uh
bigger than that
rockworker was definitely like that you
were kind of like so weird that's so
cool yeah and they had they had camping
there we didn't we actually biked to
to the festival in that that situation
but but they did have camping and it
reminded me a lot of bonnaroo when we
were walking through it
and i know bonnaroo was um you know
designed to be kind of like a european
festival so i it did remind me a lot of
that
so
first off you know we haven't even said
this i mean thanks for thanks for
joining joining us and thanks for
jumping on and doing this for uh you
know talking about festivals and and i'm
surprised that we haven't uh talked
about
talked about boundary with you before
but um specifically about boston calling
um
you guys can have an opinion about this
if you want i mean if you don't it's no
problem but
i wonder if there's a reason
this thing is always so well done and
it's because it's
an independent operation barry you know
when when the conglomerates start taking
over a lot of these festivals you know
you get a lot of the same things
happening in every part of the country
and boston callings still maintain their
independence here i wonder if that has
helped
um
the overall feel of that thing always
seeming to be
a tad different than everything else
yeah i i i can't disagree it's it's it
goes back to what we've been trying to
get at i think for this whole time we've
been doing this show is what's the
mission
you know what's the purpose for doing it
and uh the ones that seem to be doing it
well have a a really clear
mission
and whatever that is you know we talked
about last week uh
um
you know the forecastle seems to hit a
home run with
younger
fans it's maybe not for us but it's hit
a home run with a certain
uh group and i think those the ones that
know what they want to do
and and are able to do it um
are the ones that you know seem to do it
right every year when you guys are there
do you
since it's mostly locals or is it a good
mix of out of town or so
i would say it's a good mix yeah um
definitely a lot more locals but um
well it's a college town and it's
memorial day weekend so i feel like
there are a lot of kids there um since
it's the end of the semester but there
are a lot of people that browse into you
but it doesn't feel young
no no not really no there's people of
all ages um you know there's a lot of
grad schools there and then you know
we're a bit older and professors are
there right because
because for comparison how could you
tell the patches on the on the jacket
[Laughter]
it's the reading glasses very it's
walking around like this yeah
they've got a monocle the um the thing
about the the
shaky the shakiness comparison's
interesting because
and this is no fault of theirs but
shaking these even though it's a really
well do i actually like shaking these a
lot and you know they've really dialed
in to exactly what they want to be the
last few years i do feel like it's still
sort of young i feel i feel like the
shakiness crowd is is just inherently
young mainly because you know maybe it's
just atlanta but boy
nothing is as young as i've ever seen as
lollapalooza i think
it feels like the average age is like 16
and a half at lollapalooza i've never
been around
um
i i'm the most geriatric person in the
entire crowd it feels very odd uh so i
wonder does it feel that young
like
okay yeah yeah and having been to
lollapalooza the the one time i would
agree i think i was a little
taken aback by how how young gets skewed
let me yeah i actually i actually have
i was actually told and i don't really
want to get into it but
the amount of beer that they sell
is actually not even close to any other
festival
in the in the in the portfolio because
the crowd is that young they told me the
average age one year and it would stun
you it would stun you oh i believe it
maybe i'm trying to ask you guys brad's
question um i mean because
do you go to boston calling because you
have family there because of the lineup
and do you think it would do
well numbers wise ticket sales wise
no matter what the lineup was because
it's memorial weekend and it's a college
town and
and those sorts of things
if i think it hasn't
yeah i would think it has a lot to do
with the lineup and just the the overall
makeup of the lineup and the location of
it with it being so walkable
um
it was it's a combination of all the
things yeah and it was always one of
those festivals that was uh
you know on our agenda to eventually hit
it just kind of matched up with uh her
having family there so that kind of took
away that additional stress of you know
where are you going to stay
because you got to put your body
somewhere at night so
i would say it's definitely the lineup
too because i do feel like they do pick
their lane and try to skew it
towards the audience that they want and
um you know it may skew towards
uh college-age kids it but i i think um
it's just an overall lineup is always
strong
like we bought our tickets when they
first went on sale for the pre-sale
because we thought rage against the
machine was going to be there uh we're
going to have a family reunion with my
cousins to go i'll go see rage but you
know even with them unfortunately having
a drop out i feel like it's a solid
lineup
and it has been most years
and and what is the ticket price like
well it was around i think now it's
around like 330 they i know they what's
still high yeah
it didn't start that way they had their
same tiers kind of like bonner i think
it started around like 2 50. yeah i
think they were about 250. in comparison
i wonder what the shakiness ticket is
barry
i don't i don't know i'll stop my head
um
i wonder though and and if you don't
have any answer to this that's fine
first off i think that there is
you get a lot of help when you have
somebody like aaron curating the
festival with you you know you can uh
call in a lot of favors when uh you've
got him uh making the calls but the
second thing is i wonder why
and if you had any like i wish that i
could talk to somebody from boston
calling i wonder why they went from two
weekends to one i wonder if there's like
a strategic reason
um maybe a financial reason whatever i i
i love this idea of
being curated two times a year
and then
um you know getting two completely
different lineups that way you know
coachella of course does the two
weekends and and you know
that's fine but boy it's really
interesting because we argue that we
didn't argue but we did hear rumblings
bear years ago that bonnaroo wanted to
do
two different festivals a year and they
wanted to do a bonnaroo spring and a
bonnaroo fall uh then that transitioned
to well maybe it'll be bonnaroo and then
a country bonnaroo and then it became
bonnaroo and a hard rock bonnaroo um
yeah that phone never got never got legs
never got off the ground but real quick
one question there's a reason there's a
reason why they don't do it and i wonder
what it is
yeah it didn't work
um i'm talking about boston calling i'm
awesome
there's a reason why they don't do two
weekends and i and i and i just
i don't know maybe maybe because it's
financial stuff i don't know maybe the
answer is really simple i just i just
don't know what the answer is well i
would also wonder if it has to do a lot
with uh the timing of coming in with
memorial day and some of the students
because i imagine that's a lot of their
audience is trying to grab those
students before they
head off to do whatever they need to do
for the rest of the summer and so i
guess they just
kind of just condensed it to one weekend
really concentrate and focus on getting
the best they can because it seems like
especially looking at um
like coachella
how they have their two weekends that
seems a little easier for them to manage
i don't know with on the scale of boston
calling if that's if that's something
that they can contain
having all those same artists stay in
that area
oh yeah i don't know we'll have to find
somebody ask but to your question brad
shakinese the ga is 205
uh ga plus and i don't know what the
difference is is 430.
yeah
and then on up
the three-day ultimate pass is 7 500. so
i'm gonna put us down for two yeah go
ahead and yeah why it too make it well
rusty sleep on the floor um i
i mean look i i think that um
i'm sorry to be completely out of touch
here uh and i'll get roasted for this
but
when did the prices get this high
when did the rent get so damn high
they're in too damn high i uh
is this is this is this a new thing it
was that were the prices this high two
years ago before the pandemic
yeah
wow
they weren't as high i will say though
because uh last year when we were going
to go to bonner it was going to be our
first vip experience because we were
like you know what the heck let's let's
go for it
and then when they announced the prices
for this year we were like that's
that's out of the range a little stiff
yeah
yeah experiences keep going up
what was the price
i want to say it was it's i think it was
like twelve hundred dollars a ticket
yeah oh my god yeah they're 1200 and
they have a 3500 vip ticket too
oh my god uh well all said and done
though i mean you're gonna spend twelve
hundred dollars two thousand dollars on
a trip to boston for the weekend uh when
it's all said and done yeah even if you
do have friends that you can stay with
you're gonna you know you're still gonna
be spending a good chunk what are you
doing at night um are there any after
shows around town at boston calling uh
there's a lot of food we actually meant
to look up to see if they did after
shows or not because i don't remember
that we did any last time we were there
i wouldn't be surprised
that they have some kind of after shows
um and it's again really easy to
navigate so
what do you get what did you guys do
we ate and ran the train and
uh
stumbled home lots of different pubs and
yeah
good restaurants lots of good food
when you go even to the european ones
and and boston as well are you the type
to get there as soon as the gates open
or you get there when your first
favorite band or depends
kind of just get there when you feel
like it really because there and there's
so much to do in the area surrounding it
like i think for most of the days we
would go and have a drink outside of the
grounds because one it was cheaper
two the selection's better and so it was
like well you know the band that we want
to see comes on at three o'clock so
let's wander over when we all feel like
it yeah we go to museums and such too
there's always you know something to
find to do while we're doing they have
um do they have pbr in museums
that's a good question i need to do some
more research
yeah taco i don't i don't i don't think
so uh i'm gonna say no yeah
um well then i don't know i mean
that's why
uh
i mean i am i am very intrigued
the only the only catch that i have with
this is
um and this is totally i mean it's
nobody but me um i i'm partial to the
cities that i already travel to for work
um so the nashvilles the chicago's new
york sales austin like those are the
cities that i just gravitate to and i
just don't
there's not a time in my life excited
from one time when we were driving
through i said you know i should go to
boston
um
i i'm assuming that the red sox are not
in town usually on memorial day weekend
because of this or or are they in town
like the cubs are for lollapalooza
because i always like to grab a cubs
game when i go to lollapalooza i wonder
if you could do the same thing with red
sox i think you might be accommodated
yeah i feel like that they do have a
game around that time usually okay
um i mean i'm really intrigued i really
want to go uh because there's something
about this this festival that just keeps
look i mean when you realize that
there's some serious names that are part
of this and it's a completely
independent
operation uh that's been now nine years
strong barry there's there's something
that's really really intriguing about
going to this that um i know i got it
it's just been stuck in my head for the
last few weeks
yeah i i agree and i love listening to
jessica and reggie because they have
such the comparisons i mean you've been
to all kinds of different ones right
from not just bonnaroo that which is a
camping to the boston which is a
city to shakey knees to the european
ones so
um
do you have a favorite are they all just
they're all
have their advantages and you like them
all or differently
that's hard to say bonnaroo still
hits so different than everything else
but it's hard to
keep it in that same
same category as other festivals
especially other city festivals because
they have their own kind of caveats of
yeah it's like apples and oranges you
really can't compare so so i mean
bonnaroo is its own thing and that'll
always be the top because we
we've been going and we love it
denim is somewhere where where do you
guys live
oh yeah okay so yeah bonnaroo is easy
for you yeah right if bonnaroo wasn't
near you would you
be trekking it every year
not every year it would definitely be
lineup dependent and it's getting
barry i'm telling you you know i thought
that
you know living there i i didn't think
that living there was going to be the
reason why i went to bonnaroo every year
but
you know not living there
makes me really start looking around and
say ah do i really want to go and spend
it's an effort it's a week it's it's
it's an easy drive from knoxville it
seems like it would be but it's not is
it not really uh you got to come down
here and then go up yeah
and having to load the car and then
prepare and yeah
yeah it's like two and a half hours yeah
yeah is there the same
do you have i mean you have family in
boston so that's a little bit different
but do you get the same sense of
community
uh i mean the fact that you guys met
with taco at the show and came down here
i mean
what happened this year was
to me so indicative of why bonnaroo was
special i mean
brad and and uh
russ and david bruce who drove down from
new jersey and nick who's in our camp we
all ended up on my front porch
you know that side that's because we
knew you weren't going to leave the
house
well this is the only way we could see
you it's the only way we were going to
see dad is if we went to you it was
awesome
but there were so many little mini roos
is what i'm i'm getting at uh do you get
the sense that there's anything like
that from these others
some yes yeah i would say yes
yeah i went all over the place i was
like
i think that community is everywhere i
think sometimes you have to look for it
um
when we went to madpool we stayed in a
hostel in madrid and that was very much
like bonnaroo because you've got a bunch
of people that are all there for the
same reason and we you know we met other
festival goers
and spend time with them
um
i think though it just depends like city
festivals it's easy to just stay in your
hotel room and
you know maybe not interact as as often
and as much with festivalgoers until you
get there i think you just may have to
go look for it a bit more yeah it seems
a lot easier at
bonnaroo mostly because when you're
there you're all there there is nothing
else for you it's like i've i don't
think i've heard that before
[Laughter]
where did that let me
let me write that down when you're there
i'm gonna try to remember that you're
there
but at the uh the other city festivals
you do you do get that sense of
community it's just the fact of
you know at the end of the day at 11
o'clock or midnight or whatever it is
you all kind of just go your separate
ways and hope you come back the next day
the same way so mm-hmm
gotcha
gotcha well i mean this has been
tremendously informative and i
appreciate you guys perspective and
fight yeah like barry said finding out
that you guys go to you know every
festival it seems like up and down the
line that's pretty impressive why no
coachella
still still working up to it
[Laughter]
this is the first year i've dabbled with
the idea of going just because i i mean
i think it's so impossible to wrap my
head around something so completely so
far away and so completely out of my
comfort zone and i don't have anywhere
to stay i don't feel comfortable you
know flying you know my entire you know
diva like you know
wardrobe over to uh california to to
camp um i don't want to stay in la and
drive down the air the entire time so
i've been just waiting for the moment
that somebody just had a house that i
could you know bunk in
and i i stumbled upon someone who does
for the first time and
you know
i don't know barry i don't know i still
even with that possibility i don't i
still have this like odd
feeling of whether
do i even want to do this do i really
want to go to coachella i don't know
maybe the lineup
maybe the lineup the right lineup will
get you there
i mean i do love harry potter you don't
even go i mean harry styles is great
they have good restaurants in l.a out
here turns out yeah you know
you're never going to see them
i'm talking about you because you're not
going to go see the music anyway no no
no i'll be well into the city well
that's gonna be the problem like i i
wanna see that's the other thing about
coachella uh follow my logic here i'll
get a house in
the valley or wherever the festival is
but i'll still be going to la every
afternoon and evening for dinner so
where should i stay here
that's why that's why it's really tricky
for you it's really tricky for me um all
right well guys thank you so much for
not only um being a fellow bonoruvian
for being on the show uh talking to us
about boston calling it's a very
informative and and i can't wait to see
you guys if we do uh at bonnaroo all
right
we hope to see you too we are big fans
of your shows we're big fans of you yeah
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this this was great yeah thank you
thanks thanks guys we'll talk to you
soon all right thank you yeah that was
great yeah and very informative i'm not
kidding about this i seriously do want
to try and figure out how to go to this
um
you know it's just
you know it's boston and it's a city i
don't i've i've only been in for an hour
and a half so
it's it's wrapping your head around yeah
i think we would find it a lot like
louisville which i love maybe yeah i
love the festival and i love louisville
so yeah boston would be great um
i wanted to to wrap the show up with
something that happened this week that i
was really really excited for our old
buddies repeat repeat
launched a new song it came out this
past week it's called arrangements and
i'd like to play it to finish the show
if you don't mind
love it if you haven't heard it and if
you're not a familiar with repeat repeat
jared and kristen um we love them with
all of our hearts they're two of the
best people you'll ever find and i think
the song is incredible i think the song
is incredible it's like double oh seven
you know it's just so so well done so i
want to wrap up with with giving them in
their new single a uh a spin here uh
barry quarter taco anything else before
we go
have a great week oh by the way if
you've made it this far and you work or
operate boston calling
i would love to come to your festival i
agree
love to come and pick me up on the way
up yeah anything you guys want from us
we will be there that's right apparently
they listened to our show last week and
liked what we had to say oh good well
please please please if you want the
what podcast part of your festival you
just let us know
we
very rarely are but boy we're
possibilities
thanks guys see you soon
[Music]
consequence podcast network